amelia the term coda stands for child of
deaf adults um did you speak to children
of deaf adults like to kind of get that
experience i did i spoke to a lot in the
prep time and and selma my my teacher he
introduced me to some i also was finding
someone instagram and i started talking
to them like that and then we set up
facetimes
and i just i knew that i was
representing a community that i didn't
belong to and so i wanted to kind of
respect um respect that and i yeah i
wanted to find out people's different
experiences and although they were all
very similar they were also quite unique
and
all of our interpreters on set were
coders some of them here today and so it
just meant that i had so much support
and so many people that i could you know
fall to if i needed if i needed help or
talk to ask questions
absolutely it's important that you do
the research i love that because you
knew there was a weight a gravity to the
situation that you wanted to you know um
not only support but uplift this
community that
has like as you said for lack of a
better term gone on deaf ears for a lot
of people like people don't notice or
realize or think about um so it's really
important that you you dove in like that
so a big theme of the movie is how music
impacts everyone regardless of ability
and one of the guiding forces for music
in the film was the choir teacher who
was also here with us today everybody
please welcome the very talented
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh so
were you very musical before working in
this film because i got to tell you what
what was also another layer of
um selfishly watching the movie is a
choir director changed my life like
changed the trajectory of my life a very
poor kid had no
outlook for anything promising happening
you know and and and really singing and
that being my passion changed my life
and your character in this movie changes
hers yeah and so did you have like any
experience in that and are you just that
amazing of an actor because i'm like
goodness it was so because your wife is
musical your wife is musical yeah yeah
no but yeah i'm just amazing
[Applause]
when i was a kid i used to play some
piano but that's when i was a kid i
played piano and i suck now so you were
yeah so talented i really uh i was 24 7.
i was i remember i was touring promoting
another film and i was asking production
please i want to stay in a hotel it
doesn't matter if it's two stars but i
need a piano
because i i want to uh i need to
practice absolutely so i was uh staying
just in hotels where i can play the
piano and then people were asking me can
you play this one but no i'm just i'm
not the piano player i'm just
rehearsing here yeah and they were
asking for
songs for them it was crazy it was just
so well done i love what your character
represented and you know and especially
in amelia's character's life like it was
it was so pivotal like you know getting
in that car and she did it for a guy
which is so awesome like just to be like
oh you're in there okay me too and then
it changes your life it was it was
really cool
[Music]
you